alors sur une vidéo youtube une vidéo
youtube très longue qui a fait grand
bruit sur internet c'est le témoignage
de morgane anselme en cette candidate de
l'émission secret story 5 est ce que
c'était votre candidat oui mais voilà
elle est resté treize semaines sur 14
dans le jeu de tf1 avec le secret mon
père s'appelle brigitte
exactement il son père s'appelle
brigitte d'ailleurs brigitte que je
connais bien que j'adore qui était
chroniqueuse dans le grand journal un
moment je dors j'adore j'adore j'adore
cette personne elle balance toutes les
machinations qui se cache derrière
secretstory sans langue de bois et avec
beaucoup de détails
benjamin castadi vous nous direz si
c'est vrai on aura adrien lemaître donc
le producteur de l'émission qui viendra
nous voir et je veux vraiment que les
masques tombent
jouer si la compagnie créole l'on garde
c'est pas le bal masqué regardez ma
pensée allez on vous a préparé un petit
récapitulatif des parties
c'est un nouveau coup dur pour l'image
de la télé réalité en france le
témoignage édifiant d'une ex-candidate
de cyclades story qui a décidé de briser
le silence et de tout dire sur les
coulisses de ce type d'émission en 2011
morgan anselme accepte de participer à
l'émission secretstory avec le secret
mon père s'appelle brigitte
sept ans après elle balance dans une
vidéo déjà visionnée plus d'un million
six cent mille fois sur youtube
elle y raconte tout son parcours de sa
visite médicale il faut passer un
entretien psychologique alors là aussi
c'est mythique parce que normalement
c'est un entretien pour vérifier qu'ils
aient pas des gens dangereux ou fragiles
qui font l'émission mais ce qui se passe
c'est que les casteurs nous disent de
mentiras psychologue au changement de
comportement des équipes une fois dans
la maison des secrets la production
cherche à nous pousser à bout tout le
temps qu'ils veulent qu'on soit tout le
temps sous pression en passant par
l'insalubrité et les conditions de
tournage au bout d'un mois j'avais des
plaques sur le corps à cause de
l'humidité et la crasse et pire encore
selon elle le jeu serait même truqués et
là il me dit par en fait il faut pas
être bien mais en gros dés que les
nominations sont faites le mardi nous on
a la feuille de route avec le nom du
candidat qui va sortir le vendredi pour
le ramener chez lui le lendemain des
accusations à charge contre la
production et le diffuseur qui pour le
moment n'ont pas réagi à cette vidéo
alors la vidéo a été vue plus de 500
mille fois morgan a été contrainte de
respecter la clause de confidentialité
pendant sept ans puisque kelly b novelli
demandé pourquoi elle parle maintenant
parce qu'elle a dû attendre sept ans
voilà comme ça vous avez vos réponses
avant de rentrer dans la maison des
secrets la production a demandé à
morgane de mentir aux professionnels de
santé et de ne pas le prévenir si jamais
le consommer de l'alcool ou des drogues
pour être sûr de pouvoir intégrer le jeu
on va voir cette première vidéo
adrien lemaître nous a rejoint qui était
qui travaillent avec nous maintenant et
qu'ils étaient donc producteurs de
secretstory et ses rédacteurs en chef à
l'époque les producteurs parlent et se
sont souvent menti pour être
mais pas à marcher je vous avais dit que
la télé ces magouilles et comme vous
pouvez le voir il revient de turquie
puisqu'il a arrêté un blouson il ya
nicolas également qu'ils étaient avec
nous vous avez participé à secretstory
nov
une saison où adrien lemaître lieu donc
lui était producteur de l'émission ce
qui m'avait dit mais en fait il était co
rédacteur en chef de plus un mensonge de
plus dans la télé et où il avait
participé également aux anges de la télé
réalité et à fresnes streep
voilà également aux chiffres et des
lettres et a alors regardé donc morgan
comme morgane dit qu'elle a dû mentir ça
m'a fait alors je vous le dis s'il ya
des enfants qui nous regardent ça m'a
fait froid dans le dos bon voilà je
voulais alors mais ce rigoler jallet
nation je serai quoi vous aimez pas des
mensonges
alors que j'avais l'impression d'avoir
un mister freeze dans les fesses il faut
passer un entretien psychologique mais
ce qui se passe c'est que les casteurs
no 10 de mentir à ses collègues moi ils
m'ont dit si tu bois aussi tu drogue
surtout tu lui dis pas parce qu'elle n'a
pas validé sa candidature mais moi je
n'ai pas envie de mentir donc je vais
dire on écoute et on m'a dit pas vous
lisez nos mais voilà j'ai déjà pris de
la drogue dans ma vie c'est fini depuis
longtemps mais au moins et au final on a
continué à discuter
elle a quand même validé ma candidature
et elle a continué à travailler avec
endemol
ces propos bien sûr ces propos
n'engagent bien sûr qu'elle mais on
aimerait avoir un éclairage sur ce qui
s'est passé
adrien lemaître est ce que tout ce
qu'elle dit est vrai est ce qu'il ya des
magouilles nos sécrétions et après je
vais demander à benjamin castaldi
magouilles le le mot est un petit peu
fort après ya des petits arrangements
évidemment qu'à jam en a déjà parlé à
l'antenne je parle de certains candidats
pourquoi pas qui sont mis en avant par
rapport à d'autres candidats
ce qu'on fait dans beaucoup d'émissions
télé où on peut avoir un con ella qui
vous voulez mission mais ce qu'ils
avaient sur carrick 107 les vous leur
dites pas la tronche au crétacé
alors oui je profite de cette tribune
que vous me ferez aujourd'hui pour en
parler par exemple nicolas vous êtes
rentré dans la sienne dans la maison de
cire et vous n'aviez pas de secret on
vous a donné un secret mécanisée donc on
a fabriqué un secret pour vous en effet
votre secret c'était j'ai fait une
expérience amoureuse avec coralie qui
étaient sur place et donc on vous a créé
votre secret de toutes pièces mais ce
qu'on l'a assumé auprès des
téléspectateurs dont il n'est pas de
triche
par rapport
on fait partie du jeu nicolas vous
qu'est ce que vous dénoncez moi ce que
je dénonce c'est en fait j'ai vu la
vidéo du de morgan et ça m'a fait réagir
parce que ce qu'a dit en fait c'est ce
que je raconte à mes proches et aux gens
qui me pose la question
dès que j'en ai l'occasion c'est que
tout ça la mécanisation des secrets
c'est bien c'est beau et ça fait c'est
ce qui fait vendre c'est ce qui fait
regarder c'est cool et c'est le côté
positif du mensonge de la magouille le
dire mais le côté négatif c'est qu'en
fait des personnes comme moi je prends
mon exemple parce que celui je connais
évidemment souffre de la manipulation
mais ce que ça dit hadi a il ya quelques
années et c'est je le cite parce que
c'est vraiment exactement ça c'est
casteret en efficacité si vous aussi
fait que l'accroché de trois beaux et
pète un coup
ouais c'est oui pour citer mais ce cas
tu as dis donc il a dit simplement
secret story n'est pas n'est pas
scénarisée mais c'est truqué c'est
exactement ça c'est pas scénarisée parce
que nous on est pas on a pas de texte il
ya 17 mai pour rechercher sur google et
vous l'a dit alors vous met à l'aise
j'ai toujours parlé et j'ai dit que la
vérité sur ce point bas sur ce qu'elle
dit là sur le site important le coût des
psychoses ap sipa c'est très important
oui dans tout et télé réalité et c'est
obligatoire de plus en plus avec tout ce
qui s'est passé on fait passer les
cadettes vont ainsi of gabon a trak -
trop à l'aller marc massé hennebont a en
tout cas dans ce programme là c'est
important c'est vrai que quand on a un
très bon candidat
ouais qui est important est qu'on juge
important pour le programme évidemment
qu'on va tout faire pour qu'ils passent
entre guillemets l'épreuve du
psychologue mais c'est pas que
secretstory c'est tous les programmes
c'est koh lanta ce sont des beaucoup
d'autres mais c'est vrai que c'est une
scène de cette façon de s'arranger avec
la vérité évidemment si on dit ou psy
ouais je me calme je me drogue ce qui la
même chose d'ailleurs et je bois
forcément qu'on est fragilisée pour
participer au programme évidemment vous
êtes en train de dire que beinheim ne
participe
c'est malheureux ce livre de la boulette
du tajine
alors alors nicolas voulait rajouter
quelque chose et vous vous avez fait
leur star ac a oui non mais vous
découvrez le pérou à orléans excusez moi
j'ai un petit peu de géographie de
j'avais fait de la russe mais excusez
moi moi je vais bien que les premières
saisons de toutes les premières télé
réalité n'est pas eu toutes les clés en
main mais même moi à la star academy 4
j'avais déjà quelques clés et évidemment
qu'on m'a pas fait passer un entretien
vous savez la dcri moyen d'allier des
christie fort boyard star ac c'était clé
de quoi les clips non mais quoi donc
c'est quoi les clés que vous aviez dit
c'est quoi
elle dit que vous connaissez pas
expression aussi connor éjecté dans le
barillet kate avait quoi que tu peux
même pas dire qu'il y avait des choses
que je savais que ça allait être un peu
barbouillé qu'on allait être un peu
orienté qu'on allait y ce mode mais
vendu tous les sujets mais je savais
bien que y allait avoir un petit peu des
magouilles et que ça n'est pas être le
pays des bisounours on peut quand même
aussi le savoir un peu la leur mire
c'est alors qu'est mais après on va voir
le 8 octobre 2011 mais morgane est
éliminé l'agent de sécurité qui avaient
qui les morgan jusqu'à sa chambre
d'hôtel lui avouer qu'il savait depuis
mercredi qu'elle était éliminé soit
trois jours plus tôt il avait le nom du
candidat l'adresse à laquelle l'emmener
et les billets de train ou d'avion à son
nom regardez ça c'est fou ça je sais
faut surtout non c'est fou l'agent de
sécurité dans la voiture il me dit
franchement c'est nul parce que depuis
mercredi on sait que c'est toi qui sort
et on est dégoûté je dis mais comment ça
depuis mercredi
et là il me dit bah en fait il faut pas
le dire mais en gros dés que les
nominations sont faites le mardi nous on
a
la feuille de route avec le nom du
candidat qui va sortir le vendredi son
adresse et ses billets d'avion c'est
bien trop pour le ramener chez lui
l'homme a alors oui alors oui non alors
c'est ce qu'elle dit et là c'est
absolument faux dès qu'on a ouvert les
votes des cas les nominations évidemment
que on a des remontées toutes les heures
des tendances on sait qu effectivement
morgan est très mal partie par rapport à
l'autre candidat
d'accord mais ça veut pas dire qu'elle
est éliminée aline autre chose qui est
claire là totalement fausse elle dit je
n'avais pas le nom de celui qui sortent
dans le bloc c'est pas vrai c'est pas
possible lui jette justice depuis le
loft 2 le deuxième loft est là pour
contrôler l'ouverture des votes
comment ça se passe et la fermeture
s'est vu prix les sujets sont évidents
et bien mise en rayon sur le pap et
rigal adrien est ce que c'est vrai ou
parce qu'il est bien sûr eu alors oui
bien sûr c'est vrai ce que d'image d'un
déjà il ya le résultat d' enveloppe
qu'aucun camp mille comme il le dit et
surtout sur morgan ce qu'elle déclare
avec benjamin si je disais allez
christophe denis brière comment il avait
lors si l'après bal raison le plein de
christophe avait confié je vous amène
inquiéter meilleur était le meilleur qui
était la vérité maintenant alors écoutez
c'est benjamin merci beaucoup c'est vrai
vraiment ils avaient leurs styles
différents
benjamin oui merci
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on a on a les tendances en fait qui
tombent tous les jours donc à la
production on voit quel est le nombre de
votes et pour qui les candidats et pour
qui les téléspectateurs vont voter et
forcément toute la semaine ça a évolué
et jusqu'au dernier moment les tendances
observées je peux vous dire pour avoir
produit les afters secret' aussi que
derrière ont préparé les deux versions
ont préparé la mer sont candidats à l
aversion pour le candidat b
benjamin en est témoin il avait le
groupe des filles en moi je vous dit
regretter j'ai jamais regardé cette
émission de merde
la vérité que je vous aime beaucoup
ouais mais je n'ai jamais regardé je
voulais aussi je vous avais même version
une mam est rien même kwasi cmj regard
de la menace évoquée l'année à part
quand tu fais notre production parce que
je les adore non mais c'est vrai on a
franchement d'orchies jamais regardé ce
cas tu risques pas parce que j'aime
c'est parce que j'accroche pas mais j'ai
regardé plein démission d'alain je
regardais plus le loft le long et
complexe qui secrète parce que les sons
qu'ils essaient d'avoir quel savoir les
mecs un secret voilà que c'est pas
brosser les dents pendant huit jours je
pense qu'on espérait que je communique
avec les animaux juste mais compliqué ce
qui est effectivement ce qui est la
vérité vraie c'est que quand on avait
des tendances et qu'un candidat ou désir
est évidemment le sauver parce que
s'exclamer championnat par plutôt que
l'autre évidemment que toute la semaine
et ça je te rejoins toute la semaine
dans la production de la quotidienne
dans les dents dans le temps et dans ce
qu'on va mettre à l'image activement
dans le prime on a prouvé qu'on fait
tout ce qui est possible pour essayer
d'aider les candidats rêvent évidemment
magouiller
avec ap valence est où tu as castaldi
magouilles
qu'importe les techniques c'est le
téléspectateur qui doivent eux mêmes et
oui mais des fois des avantages et sans
répondre à ces données servent les gens
voter pour même sens des arrivées plus
tard on va finir avec nicolas qui
vaquent aux coups durs et là dessus
voilà moi ce soit le système de vote ça
je remets pas en cause
elle a fait une vidéo d'une heure elle
parle de tout moi il ya un truc qui
vraiment m'a marqué c'est que cet été en
fait j'ai regarder les quotidiennes de
ma saison que j'avais jamais regardé
parce que je savais qu on me fait passer
pour un con pour un canard ouvrir et je
cherchais donc simplement ce que j'ai ce
que j'ai constaté c'est le rédacteur en
chef le reste conclut la machine c'est
parlant si je trouve non loin d'ici
pourtant blues ont dû finir c'est pas
contre une personne n'y a pas de souci
c'est la machine à la machine entière
que je dénonce pour une chose pour une
chose principalement c'est que j'ai
regardé pendant quelques jours toutes
les quotidiennes de ma saison
ouais et [ __ ] on me dit des comptines
et je me suis rendu compte qu'en fait il
n'y a pas une seule mission qui était
montré je parle des missions cachés et
des missions cash et j'en ai fait un tas
la première semaine pardon que j'ai dans
ma maison et ça veut dire qu'en fait
tout ce qu'on lit tout ce que j'ai fait
la première la première fois au début
tout ce que j'ai fait au début était et
est montré comme si ça venait de moi
alors qu'en fait on vous dit cyril pour
500 euros est ce que vous pouvez aller
déclarer votre femme à isabelle non
évidemment
jv isabelle je vous aime marcher 500
euros dans la poche mais c'est pas vrai
c'est croire que ça vient de vous et
vous passer pour un con parce qu'elle
vous envoie chez alors si ba ba et ba a
alors en tout cas voilà on a vu qu'ils
avaient des arrangements et que la wii
mais bon quand on sait pas ce qu'est
l'histoire
c'est pas secrète et ça c'est une vanne
pour toutes les personnes qui nous ont
rejoints de france 3